[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
bonne année à tous bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite voici les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce lundi 4 janvier
réunion de suivi cet après midi autour
d' emmanuel macron à l'elysée la
campagne de vaccination française plus
que jamais pointé du doigt pour sa
lenteur
paris à vacciner 500 fois moins que
berlin de son côté bruxelles négocié une
commande de doses supplémentaires du
vexin pfizer bio n tech alors que
l'agencé européenne du médicament
pourrait se prononcer bientôt sur le
vexin modern à washington se dit
extrêmement déçu ce soir
la justice britannique a refusé
d'extrader julian assange aux états unis
une victoire pour le fondateur de
wikileaks et ses avocats
la juge a estimé que l'état
psychologique du lanceur d alerte
actuellement incarcéré à londres et est
incompatible avec une extradition
une audience se tiendra ce mercredi pour
une éventuelle libération le mexique lui
offre l'asile politique
outre atlantique un scrutin décisif pour
joe boyd un état de géorgie doit
désigner ce mardi ses deux représentants
au sénat américain lors du deuxième tour
lors des élections de novembre dernier
les républicains avaient gardé le
contrôle de la chambre haute avec 50
sièges contre 48 aux démocrates le camp
du président revenu pourraient obtenir
une courte majorité
[Musique]
le coronavirus au coeur d'une réunion
restreinte de travail qui a eu lieu cet
après midi autour d' emmanuel macron
alors que la campagne de vaccination en
france est très critiquée jugé
excessivement lente par rapport à nos
voisins européens on retrouve devant le
palais de l'elysée et el farj bonsoir
estelle une réunion donc au tour du chef
de l'état avec qui et pour faire quoi
eh bien écoutez stéphanie un pas
question pour emmanuel macron à de
laisser une lenteur injustifiée
s'installer c'est en tout cas ce que le
chef de l'état avait assuré à lors de
ses voeux aux français le soir de la
saint-sylvestre le chef de l'état qui
s'est dit irrité selon nos confrères du
jdd face à la tournure que prend cette
campagne de vaccination il a donc
présidé une réunion de suivi ce lundi
autour de lui le premier ministre mais
aussi à des ministres en première ligne
sur le front de la vaccination
l'exécutif qui doit faire face aux
critiques sur le lent démarrage de cette
campagne de vaccination il faut dire que
pays accuse un réel retard par rapport à
ses voisins européens au 1er janvier en
france en comptait 116 personnes
vaccinées à titre de comparaison
l'allemagne a administré plus de 200
mille doses de vaccin à ses concitoyens
au royaume uni à près d'un million de
personnes ont déjà été vaccinées et ce
alors que la plupart des pays européens
ont débuté leur campagne de vaccination
au même moment le 27 décembre dernier
en visite à l'opel à l'hôtel dieu à
paris à cet après-midi le
ministre de la santé a promis sur une
montée en puissance vous propose de
l'écouter
d'ores et déjà je peux vous dire
qu'aujourd'hui nous aurons réalisé
plusieurs milliers de vaccination dans
tout le pays
ça va monter en puissance et ça montera
encore plus en puissance à partir de
mercredi jeudi vendredi la fin de
semaine
quant aux ehpad la vaccination se
poursuit de façon progressive avec une
chaîne logistique que nous devons
absolument respecter un pour ne pas
gâcher de doses deux pour ne pas faire
l'impasse sur la sécurité
absolument indispensable pour pouvoir
réaliser cette campagne vaccinale dans
de bonnes conditions nous aurons un
million de doses disponibles d'ici la
fin de semaine
autre promesse l'ouverture de centres de
vaccination en ville avant le début du
mois de février puis outre cette réunion
à de suivi aujourd'hui un conseil de
défense et un conseil de ministres des
ministres devrait se dérouler mercredi
noter aussi qu'à partir de demain les
autorités à sanitaire ferons un point
quotidien sur l'avancée de la campagne
de vaccination et puis c'est aussi
aujourd'hui qu'a débuté le tirage au
sort des 35 français qui formeront un
conseil un citoyen ce dernier pour
interpeller l'exécutif sur sa stratégie
vaccinale
merci estelle farge et pour en parler
nous sommes avec jean christophe lagarde
président hu dei député de la 5e
circonscription de seine-saint-denis
c'est notre invité politique ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir jean christophe lagarde merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt france
on viens de l'entendre olivier ferrand
qui tentent d'éteindre l'incendié en des
nombreuses critiques d'ici demain soir
et mercredi il y aura une centaine
d'hôpitaux notamment qui offriront la
vaccination à leurs soignants ainsi
qu'aux soignante ville il y aura un
bilan quotidien en vaccination c'est une
réponse satisfaisante selon vous côté de
bord il faut regarder où on est on a
échoué sur les masques on a été minable
sur les tests on est en train de se
planter sur la vaccination
à croire qu'il faut jamais changer une
équipe qui perd que jamais changé une
stratégie qui échoue g hier publié une
vidéo qui montre mon exaspération mais
surtout celle des français qui ne
comprennent pas ce qu'on est en train de
faire depuis des mois nous vivons sur ce
virus depuis des mois nous attendons une
solution le vaccin c'est la solution
je comprends et je respecte que des
français ne croient pas dans le vaccin
etc
mais il ya 25 à 30 millions de français
qui attendent d'être vaccinées depuis
une dizaine de jours qu'on est censé
commencer à vacciner on l'a vacciné 500
personnes les allemands 200 milles où
est l'erreur
l'erreur elle est dans l'administration
sanitaire qui n'est pas en capacité de
faire alors nous annonce l'accélération
y compris avec des mesures absurdes par
exemple de dire que les médecins
personnel médical de plus de 50 ans on
va pouvoir être vacciné ah bon parce
qu'à 48 ans ils risquent pas de
transmettre le virus s'y risque pas
d'être un ange et c'est absurde ce sont
ceux qui sont les plus exposés ceux à
qui on doit tout un temps derniers on
les applaudit c'est aujourd'hui on
refuse de les vacciner selon leur âge ça
n'a pas de sens
de la même façon en france on complique
les choses à volonté pour protéger je ne
sais pas qui par exemple en nous
demandant d'aller faire une consultation
médicale avant la vaccination
aucun pays au monde demande ça aucun
médecin de france de demandes ça vous
allez faire une consultation vous laisse
quelques jours après vous réfléchissez
mais enfin madame quand vous allez vous
faire vacciner vous retirer votre
chemise ou votre tailleur et que vous
présentez votre épaule pour vous faire
vacciner vous savez
que vous allez faire et le vaccin étant
la seule solution contre le virus comme
ça l'a été contre la polio délits contre
le tétanos contre toutes ces maladies
qui ont disparu dans notre pays
eh bien les gens qui veulent se faire
vacciner doivent être libres de le faire
je comprends encore une fois qu'ils les
gens qui ne veulent pas se faire
vacciner simplement ceux qui veulent le
faire aujourd'hui il ya un million de
doses dizaine mise de la santé et bah
donné un million de bornes et qu'on y
aille
invraisemblable d'ailleurs à quoi
pardonnez moi à quoi vous imputer cette
lenteur et ses débuts ratés au système
français on parle beaucoup de
l'administration le poids de
l'administration qui ressort une
nouvelle fois un manque
voilà de volonté une prudence comment
vous vous l'expliqué aujourd'hui
clairement d'abord par le fait que les
politiques ne dirige pas leur
administration
pardon de le dire ma faim c'est au
président de la république pas
l'administration sanitaire qu'on m'a
donné le soin de protéger les français
deuxièmement parce que quand on entend
le gouvernement quand on entend ce
qu'ils sont censés organiser la
vaccination tous leurs discours sont
anxiogènes tous leurs discours
là où dans le monde entier on s'arrache
le vaccin en france on dire là on va
aller doucement va voir on va savoir il
faut savoir soit il est dangereux il
faut pas le donner soi il n'est pas
dangereux il soit donnée si le monde
entier et nos ennemis et nos propres aux
autorités sanitaires considèrent qu'il
n'est pas dangereux
maintenant il faut vacciner massivement
rapidement y aller et on est en réalité
en france dans un système où le
gouvernement par trouille est sous la
coupe des anti vaccins et la stratégie
vaccinale est passé par le parlement
comme le souhaite par exemple damien
abad
lr la stratégie vaccinale dons soit
organisé un débat doit être organisée
rapidement parlement avec un vote damien
abad qui propose un allègement des
procédures de consentement ça doit
passer par là côté je les ai procédure
proposée hier soir j'ai demandé au
président de la république d'arrêter
avec la consultation pré vaccinale que
nous sommes les seuls à organiser de
faire en sorte qu' il n'y ait plus ce
délai de quatre jours parce que les
français sont pas des crétins et ils
savent s'ils se faire vacciner ils n'ont
pas besoin de quatre jours de plus on
ces informations sur les vaccins et ceux
qui ne veulent pas très bien pour eux il
ya ceux qui en veulent déjà permettons
beurre ou le faire et puis comme je vous
le disais la stratégie vaccinale édité
par les anti vaccins par la troïka
l'exécutif des poursuites judiciaires
pour 2 je sais quoi mais ça suffit ça
suffit à un moment donné expliqué que
les soignants les enseignants les
personnes dans les ehpad doivent pouvoir
être vacciné et pour les personnes dans
les ehpad regarder ce qu'on nous raconte
romy rabat où il faut recueillir leur
consentement a on le découvre maintenant
mais ça fait trois mois qu'on sait qu'un
vaccin qui arrive ça fait trois mois
qu'on aurait dû leur demander ce sont
les personnes les plus fragiles les plus
vulnérables celles qui ont le plus fort
taux de mortalité sur 65 mille morts ces
vingt mille personnes dans les ébats
dans les ehpad
on aurait dû demander avant on le fait
pas enfin il faut arrêter et moi je
demande au président de la république un
de diriger son administration 2-2 décidé
de libérer les collectivités locales les
régions les départements et les communes
pour qu'elles organisent la vaccination
puisque son administration sanitaire ne
sait pas le faire et doit passer par des
vaccinodromes comme en allemagne le
débat ait lieu maintes fois on se
souvient de l'échec de 2008 avec le h1n1
ce qu'on doit le faire en france
aujourd'hui clairement madame j'ai été
président de la commission d' enquête
sur ce qui s'est passé les chèques gelé
voulu j'ai déterminé
l'échec de la vaccination de 2010 sur le
à shine disons les choses clairement
ce qui n'a pas fonctionné à l'époque
c'est qu'on n'a pas mis les médecins les
médecins généralistes les médecins de
ville
les pharmaciens dans la boucle
dès aujourd'hui les pharmaciens ils ont
droit de vous vacciner contre la grippe
il devrait pouvoir vous vacciner contre
le coc vide
les médecins généralistes sont ceux qui
connaissent votre famille vous
antécédents vos allergies éventuelles
c'est à eux qu'il faut confier sa part
vaccinodromes peut-être qu'il faudra
organiser mais libérons les choses vous
savez pourquoi aujourd'hui on ne donne
pas aux médecins de famille la
possibilité de le faire parce que le
conditionnement c'est à dire le nombre
de vaccins par dose pose problème mais
ils sont parfaitement capables
d'organiser une deux trois journées où
ils ne reçoivent que des patients qui
veulent se faire vacciner
on leur donne le nombre de vaccins on ne
parie pas sur l'intelligence de ces gens
on croit dans l'intelligence de
l'administration et bat l'administration
sanitaire elle échoue elle a échoué sur
les masques elle a échoué sur les tests
elle est en train d'échouer sur les
vaccins et c'est insupportable d'avoir
enfin ce qui permettrait de revivre
normalement de protéger les vies et que
et que nous ne soyons pas en situation
intellectuels politiques par des
décisions par monsieur le président la
république premier ministre par monsieur
véran de dire écoutez ça suffit vos
protections et votre centralisation
débile on va faire confiance aux acteurs
de terrain aux médecins aux pharmaciens
aux communes aux régions aux
départements et on va laisser vacciner
la seule question qui vaille c'est
pourquoi avec le même vaccin les mêmes
contraintes les mêmes difficultés la
même maladie la france est la dernière
de la classe de l'europe et du monde
nous devenons la risée du monde on a
acheté il sait très bien au niveau
européen des vaccins que personne n'en
manque et nous on a les vaccins mais
personne n'en a pas merci jean
christophe lagarde avoir été avec nous
en direct assure rt france et c'est dans
ce contexte que 12 millions d'élèves
sont retournés à l'école ce matin alors
que plusieurs voisins européens comme le
royaume uni ou l'allemagne ont reporté
la rentrée scolaire le gouvernement
français lui a choisi de la maintenir
comme prévu selon les mots de jean
michel branquart bancaire décision
critiquée par une grande partie des
enseignants et du corps médical
alors devant la crainte varrault bon
l'épidémie est celle de la mutation du
virus onglet faut-il fermer à nouveau
les écoles c'est l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir
[Musique]
et pour en débattre nous sommes avec
benjamin hammam professeur d'histoire
porte parole cgt 94 bonsoir benjamin
marc à vos côtés pierre fabre vice
président du syndicat national des
écoles bonsoir à vous aussi pierre favre
donc inquiétude on l'aura compris en ce
jour de rentrée tous les voyants sont au
rouge jérôme c'est le monde le directeur
général de la santé s'alarmant de
possibles brassage de populations
engendrés par les fêtes je vous propose
tout d'abord de regarder les enfants
reviennent de différents endroits en
france ou à l'étranger ça peut rabattre
les cartes de la situation
épidémiologique 1re en cause a notamment
la variante du corona virus qui
contamine beaucoup les enfants en
angleterre et qui au coeur des
préoccupations
l'angleterre qui a bouclé en urgence
toutes les écoles de londres pour deux
semaines
la france doit-elle suivre le même
chemin par mesure de précaution n'a
jamais à ma alors en l'occurrence le
chemin emprunté par l'angleterre n'est
n'est pas simplement suivi par par ce
pays il ya le la pologne à l'autriche
les pays-bas l'irlande
enfin voilà la grèce il ya toute une
série de pays qui ont décidé de reporter
de quelques jours ou de quelques
semaines la rentrée et donc il
semblerait qu'en france les maquereaux
nist qui nous donne souvent l'impression
dans notre pays d'avoir raison contre
tous les autres français ont visiblement
aussi l'impression d'avoir raison contre
le reste du monde
mais quand on quand on fait allusion à
la phrase de monsieur salomon elle
tranche quand même étrangement avec le
discours de jean michel blanquer rière
jean michel blanc guerre à dire
quasiment dans le texte la situation est
suffisamment satisfaisantes pour que la
rentrée ait lieu normalement
et quand on écoute effectivement
monsieur salomon la phrase que vous avez
vous même site et à l'instant eh bien on
comprend pas là encore une fois on
entend on entend des choses complètement
complètement contradictoire les motifs
pour s'inquiéter sont multiples vous
l'avez dit il y a le le retour des fêtes
il y à la baisse des températures et
puymoyen quelque chose que je comprends
pas
juste avant les vacances le 15 décembre
on nous dit écoutez jean michel blanquer
renaudies vous allez avoir le jeudi et
le vendredi et le samedi juste avant la
rentrée
juste avant les vacances pardon vous
allez il conseillait aux familles de ne
pas mettre leurs enfants à l'école parce
que ils pourraient contaminer les
personnes âgées lors des fêtes de noël
à ce moment là on a onze mille contaminé
de plus haut le 15 novembre
on sait la situation aujourd'hui plus
tôt hier on nous avions dix neuf mille
contaminé supplémentaires c'est à dire
on avait quasiment le double et on nous
dit mais vous devez tout va très bien
madame la marquise circulez ya rien à
voir
faye a rien qui se tient honnêtement il
n'y a rien qui se tient on va interroger
piaf à 20 pour avoir son avis à l'instar
de benjamin hammam nous ne sommes pas
assez prudent en france pierre fabre
vous savez c'est très compliqué de
savoir ce qu'il faut faire
les gens qui savent après coup ce qu'il
fallait faire sont très nombreux il
s'exprime souvent après mais rarement
avant il faut juste être un peu plus
précis sur ce que disait benjamin amar
mon collègue de la cgt le 15 décembre
c'est pas jean michel blanquer dit qu'on
pouvait être tolérant soit deux derniers
jours c'est le premier ministre jean
castex ce qui ne retire rien à la
boulette mais ça montre que jean michel
blanquer le ministre ait pas un seul à
la manoeuvre et malheureusement le
sentiment que nous avons c'est qu'il ya
parfois un peu de fébrilité en périodes
comme celle que nous vivons
je crois qu'il faut se souvenir des
paroles de sénèque qui disait vivre ce
n'est pas à prendre à éviter l'orage
apprendre à danser sous la pluie ce qui
est ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
on a une pandémie
on a des risques on a des difficultés et
on a des arbitrages à faire alors nous
sur le terrain on essaie autant que
possible mon collègue benjamin le sait
d'autant que moi de veiller à respecter
tous au maximum le protocole pour que
les enfants puissent être le plus en
sécurité les collègues également mais on
a aussi me semble t'il en tant que
citoyen
à comprendre que ces arbitrages sont
toujours délicats toujours à revoir
fermer les écoles retarder la rentrée ne
nous semble pas la priorité aujourd'hui
et je crois qu'on peut rappeler aussi
que l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales
tiens à ce que les écoles restent autant
que possible ouverte dans les meilleures
conditions possibles pour maintenir le
service public d'éducation opérationnel
voilà alors c'est vrai qu'on va regarder
la situation en europe dont nous parlait
d'ailleurs benjamin marc c'est vrai
qu'il n'ya plus beaucoup d'écoliers un
petit ou grand d'ailleurs qui préparent
leur cartable matin pour se rendre
on court regarder en rouge les pays où
les écoles sont fermées en bleu les
pénibles les écoles sont encore ouvertes
il y en a cinq la france la belgique
l'espagne le portugal et la suisse
benjamin marque quand on interroge
certains pédiatres notamment le
professeur cohen que vous devez
connaître infectiologues pédiatre à
l'hôpital de créteil nous dit c'était le
bon moment quand même en france pour
ouvrir les écoles parce qu'on n'est tout
simplement pas dans la même situation
aujourd'hui qu'au royaume uni ou en
allemagne
qu'est ce que vous lui répondez avec des
deux je comprends pas bien à moi quand
on entend encore une fois olivier
ferrand ou content quand on écoute le
gouvernement on comprend bien que enfin
personne n'a nié qu en france la
troisième vague était en train de de
poindre son nez que l'idée à nouveau
confinement est dans toutes les têtes
il ya au dessus de moi ce qui me choque
c'est qu'en réalité dans cette situation
comme beaucoup de français je vois bien
que la cohérence est aux abonnés absents
et et nous justement on est cohérent je
rebondis sur ce que disait mon
interlocuteur la cgt elle a toujours
tenu un discours qui était un discours
exigeant très exigeant sur notamment au
moment lorsqu'on mais on nous disait
qu'il fallait retourner à l'école
lorsque à la rentrée de la toussaint on
nous disait mais tout va très bien le
protocole est formidable on a toujours
été sur la question de la santé et je
moi je
je veux aussi vous voulez que va-t-il se
passer si parce que là les chiffres sont
en pleine explosion
que se passe-t-il si dans une semaine on
nous parle à nouveau un à nouveau dans
le confinement
on va encore avoir cette logique à deux
vitesses qui nous explique que
le virus qu'on les road dans un certain
nombre d'endroits mais il est absent
comme par magie et transsubstantiation
dans d'autres endroits on a ça a souvent
été évoquée encore hier jean michel
blanquer a dû répondre à des questions
là-dessus sur le fait qu'on ferme les
restaurants mais par contre dans les
cantines scolaires tout va très bien là
aussi tout va très bien
le cluster ne vient le virus ne vient
jamais prendre son plateau dans les
selfs scolaire c'est ridicule
mais encore une fois je veux dire le
sait bien la main armée mais la
pardonnez moi messieurs mais la question
j'ai envie de vous poser vous êtes
peut-être plus au courant que moi parce
que les chiffres est ce qu on les a on a
quand même un retour d'expérience
désormais avec ces écoles qui sont
restées ouvertes
est-ce qu'on a des chiffres qui parlent
tout simplement pour nous dira voilà les
écoles sont un cluster c'est dangereux
oui ou non pierre favre alors il y a eu
une polémique au mois de novembre sur
les chiffres précisément parce que les
chiffres de la rs ne correspondait pas
aux chiffres de l'éducation nationale
c'était l'occasion de pointer un petit
peu le drame de notre pays très sûr
administrés ou beaucoup d'experts
ce s'autoproclame experts mais ne
communique pas et donc on avait
effectivement un gros hiatus entre les
chiffres annoncés par l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanquer relais
rappelé 0,3 pour cent des élèves qui
étaient étaient concernés ce qui était
tout à fait effectivement rassurant est
négligeable
et puis les chiffres de la rs qui
comptabilisait tous les enfants qui
s'étaient présentés pour faire des tests
alors bien entendu la vérité est quelque
part dans le fait que dans les écoles ne
sont remontés que la partie visible de l
iceberg et une quantité d'informations
ne sont pas véhiculés par les parents
qui estiment ou dont le médecin
conseille de dire d'emblée côtés d'anna
fallait pas tout le monde ça va bien se
passer
et donc on se retrouve avec des chiffres
qui sont effectivement au départ d'un
doute au départ d'erding d'un soupçon
par rapport à ça je crois qu'il est sain
dans une démocratie comme la france que
toutes les voies puissent s'exprimer que
tous les scientifiques puissent avoir
pignon sur rue il faut graver faire de
cette situation où les chiffres sont
sujets à discussion de cette situation
room la situation est un petit peu
délicate en faire un
une occasion de sang froid de recul de
comparaison et je dirais aussi un
exercice de confiance parce qu'à un
moment donné je dirais que l'ancien
aussi à benjamin marre parce qu'il est
il est professeur d'histoire donc il est
sur le terrain vaut benjamin vous avez
tout simplement eu des décollectes qui
sont tombés malades parce que contaminés
à l'école où ces sujets comme le dit
pierre fabre à caution finalement on a
des doutes
alors c'est une excellente question
parce que sur le terrain moi aussi je
suis un enseignant en activité sur le
sur le terrain c'est un cirque
incroyable d'abord parce que les
enseignants n'ont pas toujours des
informations sur la situation sanitaire
de leur propre établissement où nous a
évoqué régulièrement le secret médical
ce qui est particulièrement ridicule vu
que la copie de 19 est une maladie à
déclaration obligatoire
on nous a on a aussi
il ya des troubles monstrueux dans la
raquette lorsque on a découvert il ya
vait comment dire ça et c'était la pêche
aux informations sur la situation des
cas positifs des cas contacts etc
et c'est d'ailleurs pour cela encore une
fois que à larrau à la rentrée de la
toussaint dans bon nombre dans
d'établissements en france il y a eu des
mouvements de grève et de droit de
retrait parce que alors même que on
avait une recrudescence de l'épidémie et
un nouveau confinement
le protocole n'était pas du tout adaptée
jean michel blanquer déjà à l'époque
nous disait tout va très bien et il a
fallu se bagarrer pendant une semaine
pour qu on ait enfin un protocole
renforcé donc la colère des enseignants
elle se fonde sur cette expertise de
terrain
et lorsque j'écoutais encore une fois le
ministre de l'éducation nationale hier
et bien entre ce qu'il disait et ce que
vivent les collègues sur le terrain il y
à une galaxie
je donne un autre exemple jean michel
blanquer disait hier m'ont écouté
l'absentéisme
justement lors des trois derniers jours
avant avant les congés était finalement
à la marge disait-il pas écoutez moi
dans mes derniers court j'avais un élève
voilà pierre faible à la dernière
question
voilà défaut de fermer les écoles est ce
qu'il faut encore un peu plus et surtout
est-ce que c'est possible renforcer ce
protocole sanitaire dont on parle
souvent
non je reprends comme mon collègue
benjamin à marle exemple vécu puisque
comme lui je suis sur le terrain je suis
directeur d'une école je peux vous dire
que j'ai eu à 0 absents castex moi je
les appelais les absentes castex les
deux derniers jours fermer les écoles
c'est un choix politique majeur qui a
des conséquences majeures qui ne doit
être pris vraiment dans des conditions
qui sont terribles il faut effectivement
regarder l'évolution de la pandémie les
chiffres d'ailleurs unanimes que vous
montriez est très bien faite puisqu'on
voit bien à droite où les pays qu'ils
ferment qui sont dans la façade est du
pays et la péninsule ibérique bleus qui
correspond à la façade ouest donc la
france est entre les deux je crois qu'il
appartient à tout le monde de garder son
sang-froid de faire en sorte que le
service public d'éducation continue de
de fonctionner autant que faire se peut
le jeu il faudrait être aussi plus
nuancé que ne l'est mon collègue
benjamin a marre en constatant que des
anges les enseignants ne demande pas
tous un protocole renforcé beaucoup
réclament de pouvoir enseigner sans le
masque et constate le faible taux de
létalité de la maladie pour autant le
soustraire donc si vous voulez il ya
dans le monde enseignant comme dans la
population française des gens qui
pensent qu'on en fait trop d'autres qui
pensent qu'on n'en font pas donc on a
fait passer ce qui doit nous rassembler
ses intérêts ce super du pays
l'intérêt supérieur des élèves et le
syndicat national des écoles se fait
fort d'avoir une attitude équilibrée là
dedans
et pour l'instant de ce que nous
constatons sur le terrain il y a tout
lieu de penser qu'on doit pouvoir
continuer sereinement à accueillir tous
nos élèves en maintenant bien entendu
les gestes barrière autant que faire ce
merci à tous les deux pierre favre
benjamin a marre d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de julian assange la
justice britannique refuse d'extrader
fondateur de wikileaks aux états unis
une audience se tiendra ce mercredi pour
une éventuelle libération et puis
direction les états unis une élection
sénatoriale décisif se tient en ce mardi
au lendemain de la diffusion d'un
enregistrement du président sortant qui
a fait l'effet d'une petite bombe
[Musique]
comment choisissez-vous un film un
projet un scénario un réalisateur avant
de choisir en ait choisi ce qui fait le
propre d'un acteur c'est de partager des
sentiments des idées des émotions
vous vous êtes vraiment dans le cinéma
de créateurs d'initiateur je crois que
le cinéma c'est comme la peinture c'est
comme le la littérature ça reste un art
peut-être que maintenant c'est
l'industrie qui gagne mais du coup
peut-être que ce qui va rester c'est que
les films qui seront de plus en plus
fait pour le cinéma et pas sur les
grands réseaux resteront des objets
artistiques godard qui disait cette
chose si forte
quand on regarde la télévision en baisse
les yeux quand on va au cinéma on lève
les yeux
tout est dit
[Musique]
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même on
vit tous les jours sans faire attention
que tout en dépend c'est l'unité de
mesure de toute chose une convention
admise par tous s'il arrive quelque
chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du long vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
quelle image
il laisse de luis figo maradona en
argentine il laisse une image bas d'une
icône absolue d'un dieu vivant parce
qu'il a porté très haut les couleurs
d'un pays qui était humiliée par la
guerre des malouines ce pays a gagné la
coupe du monde bien alors c'est pas une
victoire militaire mais c'est une
revanche politique et sportif sur une
défaite militaire parce que la politique
et le sport font finalement bon ménage
maradona revendiquait de mélanger sport
et politique y c'était un homme dutra
gauche on connaît sa proximité avec
castro on connaît sa proximité avec hugo
chavez
il avait cette sensibilité de toujours
incarné bien les dix khamis à dos les
sans-chemise il a toujours joué dans des
clubs qui incarnait la révolte par
rapport au pouvoir central
vous êtes en train de dire finalement
diego maradona c'est l'homme du passé ce
cap a un côté paradoxal le moins que
l'on puisse dire c'est que le personnage
n'est pas lisse et qui est multiple
aspérités et c'est pour ça que c'est un
personnage de légende
[Musique]
20h30 soyez les bienvenus en direct sur
rt france si vous nous rejoignez la
justice britannique guy non à la demande
d'extradition de julian assange vers les
états unis washington où le lanceur d
alerte australien poursuivi pour
notamment espionnage risque cent
soixante quinze années de prison
une victoire pour les partisans du
cofondateur de wikileaks réunit
aujourd'hui devant la cour criminelle de
londres en soit xavier lambert le poing
levé
la trentaine de supporters de julian
assange exulte devant la cour criminelle
dolby
nous avons gagné s'exclament les
partisans du cofondateur de wikileaks
alors que la justice britannique qui
vient de refuser son extradition vers
les etats-unis
malgré cette décision favorable ses plus
proches se veulent prudents pour la
suite
on ne peut pas célébrer nous célébrerons
le jour où il rentrera à la maison je
demande au président des états unis d'y
mettre fin maintenant monsieur le
président démolissez les murs de cette
prison que nos petits garçons est leur
père libérer julian libérer la presse
libérez nous tous quel moment
c'est une lueur d'espoir pour commencer
la nouvelle année et j'espère une
nouvelle ère c'est un jour de victoire
pour une jolie anne assange
mais il faut être prudent ce n'est pas
forcément une victoire pour le
journalisme pour justifier sa décision
la justice britannique met en avant sa
santé mentale instable une possibilité
souligné par l' expertise psychiatrique
selon la cour criminelle les critères
légaux nécessaires à l'extradition ne
sont donc pas remplies cette décision de
la justice britannique nommé pourtant
pas un terme à la saga judiciaire
le département américain de la justice
s'est dit extrêmement déçu et annonce
son intention de faire appel
pour l'avocat français de julian assange
son client est persécuté par les états
unis
l'enjeu de ce dossier n'est pas
juridique l'enjeu de ce dossier les
politiques il faut comprendre que c'est
les états unis qui demandent la
persécution d'assange et il est
peut-être temps grâce à cette décision
que tous les autres pays du monde
défendre quelqu'un qui aujourd'hui
persécutés parce qu'ils ajustent
diffuser des informations personne
qu'ils soient américains pas américain
protégé par l'amendement numéro 1 ou pas
de la constitution des états unis ne
devraient être persécutés parce qu'ils
diffusent des informations pourquoi
parce que le droit à l'information est
un de nos droits démocratiques les plus
précieux l'australien risque donc
toujours 175 ans de prison sur le sol
américain
il est accusé d'avoir diffusé plus de
700 mille documents classés secret
relatif aux activités militaires et
diplomatiques américaines notamment en
irak et en afghanistan pour échapper à
son extradition julian assange s'est
réfugiée pendant près de sept ans
derrière les murs de l'ambassade
équateur à londres mais il en a
finalement été expulsé en avril 2019 et
ensuite été arrêté depuis lors ses
soutiens à travers le monde réclame et
sa grâce auprès du président américain
une requête toujours refusé en attendant
le cofondateur de wikileaks pourrait
retrouver une liberté provisoire
la justice britannique se prononcera ce
mercredi lors d'une nouvelle audience
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
claude blanchemaison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir blanchemaison
merci d'être avec nous sur rt france
alors pourquoi cette décision de rejeter
d'extradition at elle surpris jusque
dans le propre camp de générer 100 ge
oui c'était en quelque sorte une divine
surprise y compris à l'audience puisque
les avocats s'attendait à ce que la juge
décide de l'extradition et que tous les
gens qui soutenaient hausse en jeu dans
les jours précédents avaient préparé
le à peu le terrain cette décision en
disant de toute façon nous ferons appel
le combat continue et puis la juge a
énuméré tous les motifs pour lesquels
les avocats avaient dit que
l'extradition ne devait pas intervenir
et les a rejetées les uns après les
autres tous les motifs juridiques ont
été écartés et à la surprise générale la
juge a dit mais il ya un motif
humanitaire pour lequel je ne
n'autoriserait pas l'extradition de
julian assange et ce motif c'est qu'il
est profondément dépressif et qu'il
risque de suicide et par conséquent il
ne sera pas extradé alors évidemment
vous avez indiqué dans votre sujet qu'il
y à une audience mercredi prochain pour
savoir quel sera exactement son sort en
attendant que l'appel produit ses effets
est-ce qu'il sera libre et dans la
logique du juge effectivement puisqu'il
est suicidaire il devrait être soigné
probablement dans un hôpital spécialisé
probablement en effet sous surveillance
en attendant le jugement en appel
puisque les états unis ont bien entendu
fait appel alors les etats unis ont
réagi
ils se disent déçus ce soir de ce refus
julian assange peut-il bénéficier du
prochain changement de président
américain selon vous peut-être mais ce
n'est pas sûr parce que en réalité
l'administration obama dont joe biden
faisait partie puisqu'il était le vice
president avait décidé de ne pas pu pas
poursuivre finalement du llano sange
notamment en raison des conséquences que
cela pourrait avoir pour les cinq grands
journaux internationaux qui avaient
publié une partie des documents qui
venait de wikileaks pourquoi condamner
aux 100g ne pas condamner les journaux
il y avait peut-être des raisons mais en
tout cas c'est l'argument qui avait été
retenue par l'administration obama
c'est donc l'administration trump qui a
décidé de le poursuivre et c'est ce
n'est pas étonnant qu'aujourd'hui
immédiatement après la la sentence du
juge londonien est bien le misa justice
fasse appel par conséquent monsieur
trump qui est président des états unis
jusqu'au 20 janvier continuera à
réclamer la l'extradition de julian
assange aux états unis pour qu'il soit
jugé
qu'en est-il de joe biden on ne sait pas
trop parce que en effet il appartenait à
l'administration obama
il ya une dizaine d'années il avait
qualifié julian assange de dans le fond
de virtuoses du hacking de personnalités
extrêmement dangereuse probablement
probablement il laissera l'appel se
poursuivre sans retirer la la demande
américaine et la justice britannique
devra donc se prononcer au bout du
compte en appel alors on a vu l'un des
partisans de julian assange dans ce
sujet dire voilà finalement ce n'est pas
une victoire pour la liberté
d'expression des journalistes c'est vrai
que je viens d'assange est devenu un
symbole de combat pour la liberté
d'informer clairement est elle en danger
ol est toujours en danger dans divers
pays du monde
dans le cas de julian assange s'était un
peu particulier parce que je pense que
lorsqu'il a créé wikileaks en dur ont
mis là en 1996 lorsqu'il a créé le
wikileaks
il avait tout simplement l'idée
probablement juste que le monde
numérique qui s'étendait allait
impliquer une demande croissante de
transparence de transparence de tous de
transparence de la vie privée de
transparence de la vie publique de
transparence de la politique et il a
créé cette plateforme
il s'est rendu célèbre en 2010 lorsqu'il
a diffusé une une vidéo qui montrait
deux hélicoptères militaires américains
qui par erreur apparemment tué des
civils dont deux journalistes de
l'agencé reuter évidemment
particulièrement gras et probablement il
a eu raison de diffuser cette vidéo
c'était de l'information et puis après
il a simultanément demandé à ce que tous
les toutes les personnes qui avaient des
informations puisse les mettre sur
wikileaks et il leur garantit sépare les
moyens techniques adéquates l'anonymat
absolu et donc sont arrivés les fameux
700 mille documents qui ont ensuite été
diffusées pour tout est parti ou pour
toute partie par les journaux qui
étaient associés à wikileaks
mais les journaux quand même pris la
précaution de faire le tri entre les
documents qu'ils risquaient de mettre en
jeu des vies humaines et les documents
qui au contraire ne faisait que rendre
transparents l'information est
effectivement dans ce domaine et bien il
y a deux limites à la liberté totale de
l'information et il faut que cette
liberté soit totale la première limite
c'est le respect de la vie privée mais
elle est le moins en moins respectée et
la deuxième c'est le secret d'état et là
aussi les états considèrent à tort ou à
raison qu'il y à certains secteurs qui
doivent être réservées que les
communications sur la sécurité
intérieure que les communications sur
les relations internationales que
les communications internes au
gouvernement doivent faire l'objet d'une
protection particulière
et il est vrai que pour les responsables
qui sont les hauts fonctionnaires d état
quel qu'il soit qu'il s'agisse des états
unis de la russie du brésil ou de
n'importe quel autre état européen est
bien la communication ne sera pas la
même si le haut fonctionnaire
responsable qui dans le cadre de ses
attributions écrit rapport c'est que ce
rapport va être public
évidemment il n'écrira pas exactement la
même chose que s'ils considèrent que ce
rapport doit rester confidentielle pour
que le gouvernement puisse juger en
toute indépendance et en toute
connaissance de cause pour le bien du
pays
donc ce débat va continuer ce débat
entre la liberté d'informer et ce débat
entre eux ce qui peut être réservé soit
dans la sphère privée soit dans la
sphère publique
merci claude bloch maisons aux etats
unis donald trump fait pression sur le
secrétaire d'état de géorgie pour
revenir sur les résultats d'élection
présidentielle du 3 novembre
le washington post a révélé hier une
conversation téléphonique
étonnante dans laquelle le président
sortant roux comment on va ce
responsable je cite de trouver des
bulletins de vote pour annuler sa
défaite dans son état extraits de cet
entretien à douala pareils
tout ce que je veux c'est trouver 11
1780 bulletins ce qui est un de plus que
ce que nous avons parce que nous avons
gagné cet état le peuple de géorgie est
en colère le peuple du pays est en
colère
et il n'y a rien de mal à dire vous
savez que vous avez recalculées monsieur
le président le défi auquel vous faites
face c'est que les données que vous avez
sont fausses et le secrétaire de l'état
de géorgie bradeurs avance perdent s'est
exprimé suite à la demande de donald
trump de recompter ces votes dans son
état écoutez nous avons pris l'appel et
nous avons eu une conversation
c'est lui qui a parlé le plus c'est nous
qui avons écouté le plus mais je voulais
lui faire remarquer que les données dont
il dispose sont tout simplement erroné
je ne suis pas avocat tout ce que je
sais c'est que nous allons suivre la loi
suivre le processus
la vérité compte et nous avons combattu
ces rumeurs pendant les deux derniers
mois est l'état de géorgie aux sont
organisées demain des élections
sénatoriales partielles un second tour
aux enjeux qui dépassent largement les
chaînes locales
hélène masquelier avec cyrielle
benavides bullion à peine remise de la
présidentielle mouvementée du 3 novembre
dernier la géorgie retournent aux urnes
ce 5 janvier un scrutin très attendu
dans le pays avec un intérêt qui dépasse
les frontières du pitch states de sièges
du sénat aujourd'hui occupé par des
républicains sont remises en jeu
cette élection décidera donc de la
couleur politique du sénat comme le
souligne donald trump
l'enjeu de cette élection c'est le
contrôle du sénat américain et ça veut
vraiment dire le contrôle du pays les
électeurs de géorgie vont décider quel
parti dirige toutes les commissions
écrit chaque élément de la législation
contrôler chaque dollars des
contribuables
le sénat américain une des deux chambres
du congrès et contrôlent et d'une courte
tête par les républicains hillion 50
sièges contre 48 pour les démocrates
le second tour de cette sénatoriales
partielles en géorgie verra notamment
s'affronter
la sénatrice républicaine kay l'île aux
fleurs face aux démocrates raphael
warnock et john au surf
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pensez au chemin parcouru en géorgie
pensez au chemin parcouru dans le sud
des états unis
c'est l'état le plus compétitif du pays
qui a accueilli deux élections
sénatoriales pour déterminer qui
contrôlera le sénat des états unis
la géorgie a tellement de pouvoir en ce
moment si les républicains gagnent au
moins un siège en géorgie ils resteront
majoritaires pendant les deux premières
années de la présidence de joe biden en
revanche si les démocrates l'emportent
la chambre haute basculera dans le camp
démocrate
avec 50 sièges pour chaque camp c'est la
future vice-présidente kamala harris qui
comme le prévoit la constitution devra
trancher
tout est ton jeu quand il s'agit d'élire
le révérend raphael warnock délire john
sauf que là délire daniel blackman
[Musique]
tout est en jeu en cas de défaite des
républicains
c'est le congrès tout entier qui
deviendrait démocrates la chambre des
représentants leur étant déjà acquise
joe biden aurait ainsi le champ libre
pour dérouler son programme et le
congrès élit un ainsi pelosi au poste de
présidente de la chambre des
représentants nouvelle la victoire donc
pour le parti démocrate après le succès
de joe biden à la présidentielle à ses
côtés une courte majorité démocrate au
sein de son hémicycle à nancy pelosi
sera en poste pour deux années
supplémentaires et ses derniers
développements politiques aux etats-unis
on en parle en direct depuis new york
avec shadwick amour journaliste
politique c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur ce soir
[Musique]
bonsoir shadwick mot merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france on commença
par ce scrutin dont on parle et qui se
tient ce mardi aux etats-unis et qui
doit décider de la majorité au sénat un
scrutin au combien décisif sur le mandat
de joe biden effectivement c'est décisif
pour le congrès le sénat va-t-il rester
républicain ou va-t-il devenir
démocrates traditionnellement la géorgie
et républicaine et elle le fait que je
baille allait remporter aisément acheter
tout le monde démocratique ne tente pas
à voter lors des élections au secondaire
donc c'est vraiment un mystère et les
démocrates ont même tendance à
bénéficier du vote anticipé et il y en a
eu pour sa sélection depuis plusieurs
semaines d'enquêté contre à ton avantage
mais les résultats sont encore
incertains le sénateur républicain vente
il est resté un poste où les démocrates
vont-ils emporté alors concrètement ça
voudrait dire quoique notamment la
réforme de l'assurance-santé ses
ambitions à joe biden en matière
d'environnement ou encore son projet de
contrôle des armes à feu pourrait être
bloqué par les républicains républicains
s'il n'obtenait pas la majorité ne
démontre pas de mandat au niveau du
congrès août et pratiques nationales
la victoire de jo baida lite est
suspecte la moitié du et pense qu'il ya
eu de la fraude
ils ont perdu beaucoup de sièges dans la
chambre des représentants ce qui a
choqué tout le monde on s'attendait
vraiment à celle des actuaires encore
d'autres sièges c'est un fait il
maintenant une très courte majorité
les républicains tiennent le contrôle du
sénat alors cela va rendre les choses
très compliquées
en tout cas le premier mandant de
baptême et de kamala harris
donc il va s'agir de 513 entraves et
sans doute essayer de faire appliquer
autant de décret personne n'apprécie jeu
bayonne on ne le connaît pas vraiment eu
c'est que c'est un genre de néo libérale
halak l'automne
kamala harris serait pas un peu plus
radicale mais aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
va réussir beaucoup de grandes choses au
cours de sa présidence si le sénat reste
suis républicain en france il est de
tradition souvent de donner la majorité
au président nouvellement élu à
l'assemblée pour voilà tout simplement
valider une nouvelle fois ce vote pour
qu'il puisse agir et appliquer son
programme
le fait justement que cette victoire ne
soit pas si acquises ou qu'ils aient une
courte majorité qu'est ce que ça dit que
le pays est encore finalement très
divisée bien sûr et très divisés mais ça
c'est le système américain seraient les
freins et les contre-pouvoirs dans le
bénéficiaire pouvoirs du président et a
limité par le concret je baille thème
n'est pas très populaire c'est vraiment
le vote anti tron qui l'a fait élire à
certaines personnes bien qu'étant un
public
beaucoup de personnes ont voté contrôler
président mais pour les républicains à
d'autres niveaux de pouvoir
beaucoup de personne mais nous ne
voulons pas non plus de démocrates qui
sont ils sont choqués afin qu'il y ait
un
les francs-comtois le pouvoir du
président il doit beaucoup de
conservateurs qui n'ont même pas le
gouvernement et aimerait bien qu'il y
ait un ex-aequo au sénat qui le rendent
incapables d'agir
le programme démocrate et les
politiciens démocrates sont très
radicaux il pourrait mettre en oeuvre
des politiques radicales au niveau de
l'assurance santé mais également au
niveau du du système tout entier au
niveau du voc certains démontrent
qu'elles sont débarrassés du collège
doctoral veulent changer la constitution
veulent s'attaquer au premier et au
deuxième amendement les textes
fondateurs de notre pays et beaucoup de
personnes refuse cela à vol qu'il y ait
encore des freins et des contre-pouvoirs
alors on l'a vu un donateur lui continue
clamer que la victoire lui a été volé il
a fait pression sur le secrétaire d'état
de géorgie pour qu'ils lui trouvent ces
fameuses bulletins de vote qui manquait
les presque douze mille colons réagi le
camp républicain à cette vidéo un petit
peu embarrassante tout de même à les
présenter et est très embarrassante
qu'il faut savoir que ce n'est pas
demain totalité de l'arrivée qui a été
mise en ligne par le washington post
et on dirait que le président de l'un de
ces critères détail peut lui créer des
bottes
mais si l'on met toute la conversation
il ya des avocats des deux côtés ce
n'est pas tout à fait cela donne à toi
me demande au secrétaire d'état sinon
il connaît ses accusations de fraude et
ce l'est connaissent et vidéos de
personnes qui essayent de truqué le vote
comme cette vidéo qui sont présentes
dans les médias et le secrétaire d'état
alors elle semble presque fou il semble
très naïf elles sont venues mettre au
courant de rien et il est très facile de
faire des montages qui semble le faire
parler le président du mat noir très
compétente
il est très franc ils ne choisissent pas
forcément bien ses mots cela n'est pas
ce qui ressort de la vidéo dans sa
totalité et ne donneront pas secrétaire
d'état de commettre un crime sur les
réseaux sociaux les démocrates
prétendent que c'est le cas que tonna
propres essais de la cité aux cris mais
ce n'était pas la teneur de la
conversation rapidement dernière
question à quoi doit-on s'attendre pour
le 20 janvier quelle sera la stratégie
de donald trump pour les prochaines
semaines comme il va devenir président
c'est encore des gens qui pensent que
c'est impossible mais le fendant le
magasin de porcelaine des politiques
agricoles il a changé le parti
républicain et je ne pense pas que le
parti doit revenir en arrière je pense
que donald trump à rester il nous force
très importante sur la campagne de 2024
pourrait cautionner des candidats
trouvent important cela changer le parti
qui est maintenant et son parti donc
même si dubaï dont il devient président
alors de la drogue
la pad s'évaporer certains africains ne
sont pas partant pour le programme
trompe et eux vont devoir se justifier
lorsque ils vont être en campagne face à
des personnes soutenues par donald trump
merci
beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous pour re
vu de l'extérieur shadwick moore merci à
vous et dans le reste de l'actualité
l'iran a repris l'enrichissement
d'uranium à hauteur de 20% dans son
usine souterraine de fordo une
production bien au-delà du seuil de 4 5%
prévus par l'accord international de
vienne sceller en 2015
une décision critiquée par la communauté
internationale les détails avec robin pu
elle c'est une annonce qui ne passe pas
pour la communauté internationale en
relançant la production d'uranium
enrichi à 20%
l'iran s'est affranchi des restrictions
imposées par le traité de vienne
avec cette nouvelle procédure téhéran se
désengage un peu plus de cet accord une
décision désapprouvée par l'union
européenne et israël
si cette annonce des autorités
iraniennes et mise en oeuvre elle
constituerait une entorse considérable
10 à vis des engagements nucléaires de
l'iran dans le cadre de l'accord de
vienne
la décision de l'iran de continuer à
violer ses engagements d'élever le
niveau d'enrichissement et de faire
progresser la capacité industrielle à
enrichir l'uranium sous terre ne peut en
aucun cas être expliquée sauf par son
intention de poursuivre le développement
d'un programme nucléaire militaire
israël ne permettra pas à l'iran de
produire des armes nucléaires
les discussions autour du nucléaire
iranien se sont encore tendues en
novembre dernier après l'assassinât du
principal responsable scientifique du
programme nucléaire iranien selon
téhéran
cette attaque aurait été mise en oeuvre
par israël en réponse le parlement a
adopté une loi préconisant de produire
et de stocker au moins 120 kg d'uranium
enrichi à 20 % chaque année
samedi dernier les responsables de
l'organisation de l'énergie atomique ont
confirmé être prêt à lancer la nouvelle
procédure d'enrichissement c'est le
président qui devrait donner les
directives sur cette question son
premier ordre préliminaire a été
d'envoyer une lettre à l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie atomique
ce que nous avons fait nous sommes
telles des soldats et nos doigts sont
sur les gâchettes le commandant doit
commander et nous nous tirons nous
sommes prêts pour cela et nous allons
produire de l'uranium enrichi à 20% dès
que possible
dans ce contexte l'entrée en fonction de
joe biden à la maison blanche semble de
plus en plus urgente pour la question du
nucléaire iranien le président américain
élu souhaite préserver l'accord de
vienne mise à mal depuis que son
prédécesseur
on a retiré les états unis en mai 2018
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur la gestion de la
pandémie par la france et sur la
stratégie vaccinale français cible de
toutes les critiques de la part de
l'opposition et du corps médical
alors que le pays accuse un retard
considérable à côté de ses voisins
européens
et puis nous parlerons des restaurants
il ne devrait pas rouvrir le 20 janvier
au vu de la situation sanitaire
l'officialisation de la décision devrait
tomber cette semaine selon nos confrères
d'rtl
[Musique]
oui
l'hypothèse de rendre obligatoire le
vaccin pose problème ce qui est en cause
c'est votre liberté
mais ce qui est en cause aussi c'est la
liberté des autres
et entre la liberté individuelle et la
liberté collective il faut choisir la la
la gouvernance est compliqué la pandémie
après les gilets jaunes le terrorisme
islamique ça fait quand même beaucoup
tout ça le fondement la politique c'est
la rumeur ont réagi à des rumeurs et
plus qu'à des réalités ça comme
conséquence que la politique est devenue
un métier du spectacle
la loi est un objet de communication
politique trop de lois tuent la loi et
les lois inutiles culé vol nwa
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les chinois ne sont pas des guerriers ce
sont avant tout des commerçants ils ont
négocié avec quinze pays
le partenariat régional économie globale
qui crée la plus grande zone de libre
échange du monde l'annnonce de sa
signature par vidéo à hanoi bouleverse
les équilibres mondiaux et consacre la
perte d'influencé américaine dans cette
partie nous il est clair qu'avec cet
accord le pôle économique mondiale tant
au niveau du développement que de
l'interactivité est dorénavant
durablement installé sur le continent
asiatique avec son épicentre rendez vous
compte un espace économique occupé par 2
milliards 200 millions d'habitants qui
représente 30% de la production mondiale
de richesse il est triste et même
inquiétant de constater que l'europe se
retrouve aujourd'hui marginalisée par
rapport à l'air super
[Musique]
comment choisissez-vous un film un
projet un scénario réalisateur avant de
choisir en ait choisi ce qui fait le
propre d'un acteur c'est de partager des
sentiments des idées des émotions
vous vous êtes vraiment dans le cinéma
de créateurs d'initiateur je crois que
le cinéma c'est comme la peinture c'est
comme le la littérature
ça reste un art d'être cote maintenant
c'est l'industrie qui gagne mais du coup
peut-être que ce qui va rester c'est que
les films qui seront de plus en plus
fait pour le cinéma et pas sur les
grands réseaux resteront des objets
artistiques setting godard qui disait
cette chose si forte
quand on regarde la télévision en baisse
les yeux quand on va au cinéma on lève
les yeux
tout est dit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le crime est tellement épouvantable que
je pense qu'une partie de l'église mais
comme une partie de la société ne veut
pas le voir de 1950 à aujourd'hui le
travail de la commission a permis
d'identifier trois mille victimes 1500
agresseurs ces chiffres sont forcément
très en deçà de la réalité puisque des
victimes sont décédées des victimes ne
peuvent pas parler peut-être ne
parleront jamais ça montre cette
tragédie qui lie à un système au tour
c'est-à-dire comment des agresseurs
ont-ils pu agresser 10/20 parfois trente
ans
nous sommes loin du bout du chemin à
vous savez des institutions se réforment
lentement l'église peut être encore plus
lentement je ne sais pas mais en tout
cas je pense que la prise de conscience
est fait de tels scandales de tels
drames de telles tragédies dans la vie
oblige à la vérité
[Musique]
21h sous lé bienvenu merci nous
rejoindre pour cette deuxième heure
d'émission tout de suite voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce lundi 4
janvier réunion de suivi cet après midi
autour d'emmanuel macron à l'elysée la
campagne de vaccination française plus
que jamais pointé du doigt pour sa
lenteur
paris avec ciné 500 fois moins que
berlin de son côté bruxelles nino si une
commande de doses supplémentaires du
vexin pfizer bio ntech alors que
l'agencé européenne du médicament
pourrait se prononcer lundi prochain sur
le vexin modern à une fusion pour
l'avenir celles de psa et fiat chrysler
annonce en octobre 2019 et en dépit de
la crise des deux groupes automobiles
ont respecté le calendrier est validé le
projet qui donnera naissance à 56
cette nouvelle entité se place à la
quatrième position dans le classement
des plus grands constructeurs mondiaux
en centrafrique le président faustin
archange touadéra réélu au premier tour
de la présidentielle du 27 décembre
dernier un résultat qui doit être validé
officiellement par la cour
constitutionnelle après d'éventuels
recours hier des groupes armés ont pris
le contrôle de la ville de benghazi
située à 750 km à l'est de bangui une
nouvelle offensive visant à perturber le
scrutin
[Musique]
alors que la campagne de vaccination
contre le commis 19 a démarré à travers
le monde la france est le mauvais élève
pointé du doigt passant d'une lenteur
assumer une accélération demandé par
emmanuel macron est des centaines de
milliers de doses devraient être
disponibles d'ici à la fin de la semaine
haweij a semblé olivier v en opération
de communication lundi après midi le
ministre de la santé visite l'hôtel dieu
pour assister à la vaccination du
personnel soignant
ils affirment que la campagne va passer
à la vitesse supérieure d'ici quelques
jours
ça va monter en puissance et ça montera
encore plus en puissance à partir de
mercredi jeudi vendredi la fin de
semaine
quant aux ehpad la vaccination se
poursuit de façon progressive avec une
chaîne logistique que nous devons
absolument respecter un pour ne pas
gâcher de doses deux pour ne pas faire
l'impasse sur la sécurité
absolument indispensable pour pouvoir
réaliser cette campagne vaccinale dans
de bonnes conditions nous aurons un
million de doses disponibles d'ici la
fin de semaine
i la polémique sur la vaccination prend
de l'ampleur
la france est ainsi pointé du doigt pour
un démarrage jugé bien trop lent une
semaine après le lancement de la
campagne coordonnée par l'union
européenne seulement 5 116 personnes ont
été vaccinées
un rythme fustigé par jean rottner
président l air de la région grand est
quelque part on se moque de nous parce
qu'aujourd'hui se faire vacciner devient
plus compliqué que d'acheter une voiture
et du jour au lendemain on balaie tout
ça et on vient nous dire qu'il ne faut
plus d' acceptation préalable qu'il faut
accélérer maintenant les français ne
comprennent rien les français
considèrent que ce n'est pas sérieux
c'est le virus qui fait la stratégie
ce ne sont pas les sondages d'opinion
qui font la médecine aujourd'hui les
français ont besoin de clarté de
messages sur d'un gouvernement qui sait
où il va il ne donne pas cette
impression là en europe et dans le monde
les chiffres sont loin d'être aussi bas
la chine et les états unis ont d'ores et
déjà vacciné plus de 4 millions de
personnes et nos voisins allemands plus
de 230 milles une lenteur d'abord
revendiquée par olivier ferrand mais
remise en question par le président de
la république à la suite de sa prise de
parole le gouvernement semble accélérer
la
danse ce lundi emmanuel macron présidé
une réunion de suivi de la campagne de
vaccination
entouré de plusieurs ministres désormais
il y aura un point quotidien sur
l'avancement de cette campagne en france
une stratégie vaccinale remise en cause
également outre rhin selon les
informations ce week-end des journaux
allemand der spiegel est dit ça est
rapportée par valeurs actuelles le plan
de vaccination aurait poussé la france à
refuser une offre de plus de 500
millions de doses de vaccins 13h biotech
à l'union européenne objectif
privilégier le sérum de sanofi qui
utilise une technologie différente mais
selon l'aveu même du laboratoire
français ce dernier ne devrait pas être
prêt avant la fin 2021 et vexin français
non opérationnels pour le moment
campagne de vaccination en rythme d'une
promenade de famille selon les mots
mêmes du président d'où notre question
la france est-elle la risée du monde
pour en parler nous sommes avec pierre
tattevin chef du service des maladies
infectieuses du chu de rennes bon soit
pierre tattevin merci d'être avec nous
on entendait votre collègue frédéric
amener un qui devait débattre ce soir il
nous rejoindra peut-être en cours de
route dira en substance qu on était la
risée du monde est ce que vous partagez
ce diagnostic sévère tout de même pour
d'autres pays
alors on a mal démarré ça c'est sûr les
premiers jours ont pas été à la vitesse
attendu et puis les barrières qui avait
été mise dans les procédures font que
c'était compliqué mais la bonne nouvelle
c'est qu'on a quand même très rapidement
là depuis quelques jours ré augmenter le
rythme avec simplification des
procédures et on sent une volonté
d'aller beaucoup plus vite donc on a
quelques jours de retard au démarrage ça
c'est sûr mais il faut savoir toute
façon les vaccins n'étaient pas
disponibles dans l'union européenne
avant la toute fin du mois de décembre
donc on est passé par la catastrophe
il faut juste accéléré et rectifier le
tir avec des procédures plus simples
comme la vaccination où on va on va
regarder tout de même la situation des
vaccinations vous relativiser
mais tous même les chiffres ne sont pas
glorieux je vous propose de le découvrir
sur ces images un la france qui
vaccinent 500 fois moins tout de même
que l'allemagne 516 personnes vaccinées
en france au bout d'une semaine contre
114 mille personnes en italie près de
deux cent trente neuf mille en allemagne
près d'un million au royaume uni qui a
lancé sa campagne de vaccination en
avance le mois dernier et qui on précise
a pu quand même acheter davantage de
vaccins pfizer bio ntech si on regarde
dans le monde alors là on en a carrément
le tournis 4 millions et demi de chine
on a vacciné 4,2 millions d'américains
huit cent mille personnes en russie plus
d'un million en israël soit 13% de la
population immunisés on a beau
relativiser tout de même monsieur tas de
20 ça fait beaucoup de retard à ce qu'il
est rattrapable ce retard vous en tant
qu infectiologues est-ce que vous n'êtes
pas inquiet tout de même
alors quand vous dites ça fait beaucoup
de retard c'est vrai que les chiffres
sont assez effrayant mais en fait on a
une semaine de retard puisque les
vaccins sont disponibles depuis dimanche
dernier on a une semaine de retard donc
il faut qu'on a eu beaucoup plus vite il
faut qu'on vaccine des dizaines de
milliers de personnes puis des centaines
de milliers de personnes tous les jours
mais le matériel est en place les doses
sont disponibles les congélateurs sont
dans les différentes régions positionner
donc on peut rattraper tout ça je
partage votre constat pour dire qu'on
est loin derrière les autres
mais c'est une semaine de retard c'est
pas moi c'est pas quelque chose qui
rattrapable enfin si on fait un calcul à
ce rythme là on y est encore comme
diraient certains dans donc quelques
mois voire dans quelques années le
patron des députés
les républicains damien abad plaide pour
qu'un nouveau débat sur la stratégie
vaccinale soit adoptée au parlement et
surtout ça vous concerne peut-être plus
longtemps médecin alléger les procédures
de consentement est ce que c'est de cela
qu'on a besoin aujourd'hui
finalement ceux qui ont envie de se
faire vacciner et ben qu'ils y aillent
et qu'on arrête voilà de faire ce délai
de quatre jours qui complique les choses
absolument il ce délai de quatre jours
et quelque chose de c'est vraiment un
frein pour que ça fonctionne bien et en
plus ça véhicule le message qu'on a à
faire à quelque chose dedans
heureux alors que pour l'instant il n'y
a vraiment aucun signal qui suggèrent
qu'ils aient des effets indésirables
graves de manière fréquente avec ce
vaccin c'est certainement moins de un
pour cent mille
on a des très bonnes informations sur
les premiers pays quand on fait beaucoup
sur le fait qu'il n'y a pas d'effets
indésirables graves
donc il faut vraiment aller plus vite sa
chute je partage tout à fait cet avis là
c'est juste sur l'importance du retard
que je pense que on peut rattraper ça en
une aux deux semaines
si on fait bien les choses c'est vrai
que la france a sans doute été freinée
par le scepticisme légendaire des
français dans le domaine de la
vaccination
je vous propose de regarder le dernier
sondage en date 58 % c'est-à-dire six
français sur dix ne veulent pas se faire
vacciner soit plus de 8 points par
rapport au mois dernier est ce que ce
n'est pas ça aussi le principal frein
c'est vrai que les autorités avancent un
petit peu avec un boulet à la jambe si
j'ose dire
c'est une des explications qu'ils ont
donnée pour expliquer tout tous les
freins qu'il y avait au démarrage de
cette campagne il ya une semaine mais ce
n'était pas une bonne explication
probablement parce que c'est pas en
rajoutant tout c'est toutes ces
barrières à la vaccination qu'on va
pouvoir rassurer les gens il faut juste
qu'on le fasse et qu'on le fasse bien
avec un accompagnement médical des
personnes vaccinées mais sans rajouter
des contraintes comme ce fameux délai de
4 jours entre l'autorisation enfin le
consentement donné par le patient et
l'administration du vaccin ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui nous freine
et qui a aucune justification
alors pour tenter peut-être de
convaincre les plus indécis il y en a
comme on vient de le voir emmanuel
macron a proposé un collectif de
citoyens 35 citoyens français tirés au
sort
voilà qui se recruteraient cette
campagne de vaccination est ce que on
prend le problème dans le bon sens
qu'est ce que quel est l'avis du médecin
que vous êtes assez une bonne idée en
tout cas parce qu'on a vu pour les la
problématique de la vaccination
obligatoire de l'enfant le fait de faire
réfléchir et travailler ensemble des
citoyens des experts avaient permis
d'aboutir à quelque chose qui a été bien
acceptée après dans la population
générale
c'est une bonne idée ça aurait peut-être
pu être fait un petit peu plus tôt
mais en même temps le problème actuel
c'est pas tellement l'hésitation
vaccinale puisque même s'il y a que 50 %
des gens qui veulent se faire vacciner
ça fait quand même 30 millions de
personnes dont on a on a suffisamment de
volontaires pour se faire vacciner
actuellement c'était le problème
actuellement c'est plutôt de simplifier
les procédures pour pouvoir faire
beaucoup de gens tous les jours et et
pouvoir avoir une population de plus en
plus protéger
en 2008 le chemin cas lors de la 2 5 ha
on avait mis en place ces vaccinodromes
ses gymnases qui accueillait les
populations est ce qu'on n'aurait pas dû
faire finalement la même chose à ce que
ça serait souhaitable aujourd'hui selon
vous en tout cas on sent qu'on se dirige
vers ça va le fait d'avoir une offre de
vaccination à haut débit les endroits où
on puisse vacciner beaucoup de gens s'il
ya beaucoup de gens qui souhaitent se
faire vacciner
ce qui n'avait pas bien marché en 2009
là c'est le fait que les médecins
généralistes n'avaient pas été bien
impliquée dans le projet
la procédure de vaccination qui fait que
alors que c'est eux qui connaissent le
mieux la vaccination mais qui font ça le
mieux en général il faut qu'ils soient
impliqués là même si on a des grands
centres de vaccination qui sont ouverts
il faudra qu'on travaille avec les
médecins généralistes qui connaissent
les patients qui connaissent bien la
vaccination mais pierre tattevin
pardonnez moi mais ça ça fait des
semaines déjà qu'on en parle comment ça
se fait finalement que ça n'ait pas été
mis en place que les médecins ne soit
pas déjà au courant n'implique pas déjà
les patients concernés selon vous
l'histoire des centres de vaccination ça
use a eu vraiment le retour qu'on en
avait eu en 2009 était une des raisons
pour lesquelles l'hésitation vaccinale a
autant augmenter à l'époque non à
l'époque ça avait été une mauvaise un
mauvais choix et ça nous a pas aidés
cette fois ci ce qui est différent c'est
d'abord on a beau lui re j'en sais
beaucoup plus net pour tout le monde il
faut qu'on vaccine plusieurs dizaines de
millions de personnes avant l'été ça
tout le monde est d'accord là dessus
et l'autre chose c'est que la population
a beaucoup plus conscience de la gravité
de la maladie puisque tout le monde a vu
autour de soi des gens souffrir de
lakovic 19 tout le monde a vu ce que ça
a eu comme impact sur la société dont je
pense que les gens sont plus prêts
maintenant à ces grands centres de
vaccination et qu'on doit pouvoir les
mets
en place mais encore une fois pour les
jours qui viennent là c'est pas ça dont
on a le plus besoin c'est d'avoir des
des schémas de vaccination qui soit
rapide rapide et facile à mettre en
place dans les hôpitaux qu'on puisse
aller rapidement aux dizaines de
milliers de personnes à vacciner dont on
a besoin
attendu à l'information dont on parlait
tout à l'heure celle du spi galets et
dénis zeiter a porté d'ailleurs par le
français valeur actuelle la france qui
aurait refusé une offre de plus de 500
millions de doses du vaccin 13h bio
ntech à l'union européenne pour
privilégier en faire du protectionnisme
ça se fait dans tous les pays pour
privilégier sanofi sauf que sanofi n'est
pas du tout prêt alors actuelle est ce
que c'est de cela qu'on souffre des
lobbys peut-être des laboratoires et de
l'absence de ce vaccin français qui fait
cruellement défaut aujourd'hui
je crois vraiment glace est un peu hors
sujet parce que finalement on a les
millions de doses disponibles à pour
vacciner les patients dès ce mois de
janvier
donc c'est pas parce qu'on n'a pas les
vaccins qu'on vaccine pas c'est parce
qu'on n'a pas encore activé le système
de vaccination et j'ai jamais entendue
dans les discussions avec les collègues
des gens dire attendez on va attendre
d'avoir un vaccin français je crois que
c'est vraiment pas le sujet ils sont
déjà en nombre de vaccins fiscaux ils
vont beaucoup plus vite que nous pour
vacciner ils sont déjà à se demander
voilà où sont les vaccins aussi il y
aura des doses nécessaires et ça ne
semble pas être le cas d'où la grogne
dans le pays
la distribution des doses du vaccin
kaiser dans l'union européenne s'est
fait au prorata de la population donc au
mandat a autant par habitant que
l'allemagne qui sont en manque parce
qu'ils ont été beaucoup plus vite et
nous c'est pas le problème du manque
c'est pas parce qu'on attend de vaccins
sanofi c'est juste qu'on ne pensiez pas
mis en route au bon rythme la semaine
dernière quand le vaccin était
disponible alors on fait tous le même
constat et si les chiffres que nous a
démontré on n'a pas démarré comme il
fallait
vous êtes optimiste pour l'avenir on est
on est attentif 1 mais les bonnes
nouvelles c'est qu'au bout de trois
jours quand ça a râlé quand les gens ont
dit ça va pas assez vite il faut changer
le gouvernement a vraiment changé de
braquet là ensemble et dès ce début de
semaine vous allez voir je pense que
c'est vrai
les chiffres mais plusieurs milliers ou
dizaines de milliers de personnes vont
être vaccinés tous les jours versus des
instants de la semaine dernière donc on
sent qu'il ya eu une prise en compte de
la grogne un peu général et notamment
des scientifiques et que le gouvernement
a changé de stratégie et passe à quelque
chose de beaucoup plus rapide après on
est vigilant on va surveiller on va
regarder les compteurs et on va voir si
on rattrape le retard qu'on a pris cette
première semaine
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
pierre tattevin et veuillez nous excuser
puisque vous deviez débattre avec
frédéric année qui malheureusement eu un
problème technique dont ce sera pour la
prochaine fois merci en tout cas d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
pierre tattevin et la réouverture des
restaurations reporter ce ne sera pas le
20 janvier selon nos confrères de rtl
qui cite des sources gouvernementales
hop là c'est un nouveau coup pouce pour
un coup dur pardon pour le secteur qui
suivit de très lourdes conséquences
économiques liées à la crise sanitaire
une conférence de presse pourrait avoir
lieu dans les prochains jours pour une
annonce officielle et pour en parler
nous sommes avec christophe chira
restaurateurs représentants du collectif
les pendus
bonsoir christophe chira merci d'être
avec nous on imagine voilà que vous avez
fait grise mine en entendant cette
information relayée par nos confrères
d'rtl sera a priori officiel cette
semaine mais vous vous attendiez vous à
un tel repas oui bien sûr on s'attendait
à un tel report absolument n'ai aucune
illusion sur le fait qu'on n'allait pas
ouvrir alors aujourd'hui quel est votre
état d'esprit vous vous y attendiez mais
voilà vous êtes quoi résigné en colère
non n'est certainement pas résilié on
est très en colère évidemment puisque
finalement on est utilisé par ce
gouvernement pour masquer quelque part
c'est incompétence et son incapacité à
gérer cette crise et du coup ça devient
très pénible parce que les conséquences
vont être vraiment dramatique sans plan
social au niveau de nok de nos collègues
pas seulement les restaurateurs à même
les commerçants sont sont très ennuyée
donc évidemment on est extrêmement en
colère brillant compte bien mettre ce
gouvernement face à ses responsabilités
parce que trop c'est trop et on peut
bien laisser comme ça tous les mois
fermer nos jours rires sans savoir où on
va c'est pas possible est ce
qu'aujourd'hui finalement vous sentez le
soutien de la population française parce
que c'est vrai que c'est un sujet
extrêmement compliqué on est peut-être à
la veille d'une troisième vague
voilà tout le monde se dit ça nous
embête tous d'avoir les restaurants
fermés mais dans le même temps la
situation est compliquée clairement vous
vous sentez soutenu par les populations
on se sent soutenu oui bien sûr c'est à
dire que la population comme vous dites
commence à comprendre aussi
ce qu'on comprend nous nous on va un
petit peu plus vite parce qu on y est
confronté du matin au soir
mais bien sûr tout le monde commence à
comprendre que toutes ces mesures n'ont
finalement pas tellement d'effet ou pas
d'effet du tout nous ne resterons n'ont
jamais été des zones de contamination
telle qu'on veut bien au charme nous le
faire croire
c'est pas vrai personne n'aime la tester
c'est pas vrai et bien sûr que les gens
commencent maintenant à comprendre
beaucoup se disent quelque chose cloche
parce que finalement on a accepté toutes
ces mesures
et puis pour autant comme vous dites
d'ailleurs vous même et on est là on est
à la veille d'une troisième vague alors
où est le problème exactement dans ce
pays qu'est ce qui se passe exactement
on sait pas mais ça vient pas de nos
finalement christophe sira pour vous
finalement quelle est la pire injustice
dans cette affaire c'est vrai que
certains restaurateurs parle des écoles
ouvertes avec des comptines d'autres
voilà qui commentait cette scène avec
cette miss france dans le centre
commercial avec des personnes voilà
certes masqué mais pas toujours
quelle est la pire des choses finalement
pour vous restaurateur aujourd'hui
écoutez moi je vous dirais très
honnêtement que la pire des choses c'est
pas ce qui se passe c'est ce qui se
passe pas ma foi s'il ya un peu de vie
quelque part dans ce pays je suis pas
certain que ce soit à blâmer
nous sommes la seule chose qu'ils ont
trahi la justice c'est d'une part ce qui
se passe pas c'est que nous soyons la
variable d'ajustement est petit commerce
voilà les petits établissements et pas
les grands comme vous le dites qu'ils
sont pour eux pour le coup certainement
des endroits en forte hausse de risque
de contamination par ce que tout le
monde qui est pour tous alors évidemment
ça c'est une injustice et le deuxième à
justice et la différence de traitement
entre tous les commerçants et au titre
de ce fameux fonds de solidarité qui
n'est pas du tout équitable
licques et qui va faire des délais
shalit en très grand nombre dans les
mois qui viennent et ça ça va être une
catastrophe on peut nous dire tout ce
qu'on veut que la france mais des
milliards et des milliards
les bains la française mais pas les
milliards là où il le faut elle ne met
pas pour tout le monde en tout cas et ça
ça va pas du tout non plus et du coup
nous on engage une procédure très
officiellement pour obtenir une
indemnisation des pertes et non pas des
aides
parce que les choses doivent être justes
elles doivent pas être décidées comme ça
avec des forfaits qu'on donne à qui on
veut ou à qui ont peu ou à qui on décide
dans un tableau excel ça ça va pas du
tout il ya un vrai problème d'équité
dans le traitement de soutien aux
commerçants et aux restaurateurs
du coup le gouvernement qui doit
annoncer des dispositifs dead prolonger
autant que nécessaire en disent ils
c'est prendre le problème dans le
mauvais sens selon vous c'est prendre le
problème dans le mauvais sens c'est à
dire que le gouvernement décide de nous
charmer encore on nous a pas demandé
notre avis et quand on donne tout le
monde s'en fout et quand on expliquer
que l'on produit des éléments pour dire
que chez nous les choses se passent bien
et qu'on est des gens sérieux
tout le monde s'en fout alors très bien
le gouvernement décide de nous maintenir
charme et donc que le gouvernement
assume et qu'on arrête de nous parler
des aides on veut pas d aide nous on n'a
rien demandé donc provient pas des ailes
on n'a jamais demandé des aides si on
est des indépendants c'est bien parce
qu'on est indépendant et qu'on veut le
rester
malheureusement nous en empêche donc la
moindre des choses c'est effectivement
qu'on en soit indemnisé et pas aidé
c'est une vraie indemnisation dont on a
besoin
les conséquences sont dramatiques nos
fonds de commerce ne valent plus rien ça
va au delà du chiffre d'affaires perdu
aujourd'hui clairement il ya beaucoup de
scepticisme a évidemment dans le pays on
le sait quand on vaccin mais voilà
beaucoup de spécialistes pensent que
c'est la seule solution est évidemment
pour s'en sortir quand vous voyez la
lenteur
du des vaccinations dans le pays ça vous
inspire quoi encore plus d'inquiétude
bah écoutez moi je n'ai pas à me
prononcer sur le mal qui je suis pas un
scientifique donc évidemment que ce
vaccin fait beaucoup parler en tout cas
si comme vous le dites beaucoup de
spécialistes disent que c'est la seule
solution effectivement on doit vraiment
se poser une question sur la rapidité de
sa mise en oeuvre et sur les conditions
logistiques de de son déploiement
moi j'en sais rien je suis pas une
spécialiste moi je fais des entrecôtes
vous savez donc moi quand j'ai des
entrecôtes affaire je dis pas à mes
clients de venir dans droite dans trois
jours les manger je l'achète faudra
venir le virus disparaisse pour qu'on
puisse manger vos entrecôte mon cher
christophe gérard bien bien sûr bien sûr
bien sûr mais on verra bien à ce moment
là il faut effectivement que encore une
fois toujours les mêmes le gouvernement
fasse son boulot ne je veux dire je sais
pas moi s'ils savent pas déployé le truc
il faut qu'ils demandent à leurs amis de
d'amazon ou juste parce qu'ils ont des
chaînes de logistique apparemment on
sait pas où ça c'est pas notre problème
en vérité très bien si ce vaccin
fonctionne et si ce vaccin permet
d'éradiquer le virus qui a priori ne
semble pas être le cas quand on écoute
effectivement les scientifiques ils
disent qu on sait même pas si on va
rester contaminants pas contaminantes ça
devient assez compliqué cette histoire
mais nous ça nous regarde pas ça nous on
veut travailler et essayer on n'a pas de
nous mettre sous cloche cependant encore
des mois en attendant les résultats d'un
de déchets d'un vaccin qu'on n'a même
pas encore mis en route
on marche sur la tête on marche on a
peut-être ce soir le royaume uni a
décidé de reconfirmer totalement pour
deux semaines ça vous inspire quoi une
grande inquiétude également pour notre
pays
oui le royaume-uni a décidé j'ai vu que
les causes les décidé aussi pour tout le
mois de janvier ça devient une habitude
maintenant vous rendez compte c'est une
habitude c'est à dire qu'on recompte
fils maintenant comme on va acheter le
pain est bien reconduire les gens
pourraient donner la priorité à autre
chose sans doute merci christophe chira
restaurateurs représentants du collectif
les pendus merci d'avoir été avec nous
et bon courage à vous
et au royaume uni justement on le disait
boris johnson qui annonce ce soir un
retour au confinement total pour le pays
qui est devenu ce lundi le premier
administrer le vaccin mis au point par
le laboratoire astrazeneca et
l'université d'oxford
une lueur d'espoir alors que la
situation sanitaire ne cesse de se
dégrader jour après jour outre-manche
depuis le 29 décembre le nombre de
nouveaux cas recensés quotidiennement
des pas systématiquement les 50000 est
détaillé avec tintin mauclair à 82 ans
bryan singer est devenu ce lundi matin
la première personne à recevoir le
vaccin mis au point par le laboratoire
astrazeneca à l'université d'oxford et
bien le vaccin signifie tout pour moi à
mon avis c'est le seul moyen de
retourner à un peu de vie normale ce
virus est terrible non alors que le
sérum de l'américain pfizer bio ntech a
déjà été injectés à plus d'un million de
britanniques
les autorités du royaume uni vont
désormais pouvoir distribuer massivement
le vaccin d'astrazeneca offord 100
millions de doses ont été commandées par
londres désigné par axel et c'est un
nouveau vaccin
c'est une nouvelle production jacques
l'eau doit être examinée avant d'être
distribués nous avons environ un demi
million de doses d'astrazeneca cette
semaine nous en recevons plus au cours
des semaines et des mois à venir
mais notre objectif au nhs est
d'injecter les vaccins que ce soit celui
de pfizer ou d'astrazeneca dans les bras
des gens dès que nous le recevons donc
si nous recevons deux millions de
vaccins par semaine alors notre objectif
est d'en injecter à autant de personnes
de son côté boris johnson s'est rendu ce
lundi dans un hôpital londonien pour
observer le personnel hospitalier à pied
d'oeuvre
un peu plus tôt dans la matinée son
ministre de la santé avait qualifié le
démarrage des injections du vaccin
d'astrazeneca oxford comme un tournant
pour la vaccination britannique bha des
déshérités fco c'est une situation très
difficile en termes de propagation du
virus
mais nous avons aussi cette très bonne
nouvelle ce matin c'est réellement un
moment charnière avec l'arrivée du
vaccin d'astrazeneca oxford dont les
hôpitaux du royaume uni outre le royaume
uni l'argentine et l'inde ont également
autorisé l'utilisation du vaccin
d'astrazeneca oxford
de son côté l'agencé européenne du
médicament a jugé la semaine dernière
comme peu probable une autorisation dès
le mois de janvier
du sérum britannique au sein de l'union
européenne
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
nous parlerons de la fusion entre psa et
fiat chrysler annoncée en octobre 2010
un fan est désormais actée cette
nouvelle entité se placera à la
quatrième position dans le classement
des plus grands constructeurs mondiaux
et puis direction la centrafrique qui
attend les résultats partiels de
l'élection groupe et dans un climat
tendu
[Musique]
vous insistez beaucoup sur l'aspect des
dépenses publiques ce que je critique
c'est que on est dans un état
d'addiction de grande dépendance à la
dépense publique je ne veux pas du sang
et des larmes le sang et les larmes on
les a déjà trop de dépenses trop d'état
je pense en tout cas qu'il ya trop de
bureaucratie
c'est à dire un état inefficace tout ça
a été financée essentiellement par de la
dette
le problème est moins la dette en
réalité moi je pense qu'on remboursera
la dette par la croissance donc il faut
essayer de libérer l'économie française
et notamment le travail
notre problème en france c'est un
problème où la dépense publique est
excessive
mais surtout elle n'est pas productive
les français n'en ont pas pour leur
argent
de ce point de vue emmanuel macron n'a
rien changé par exemple par rapport à
son prédécesseur françois hollande
la france oubliée c'est une rencontre
avec ces citoyens qui ne se résignent
pas à la fatalité
on est comme tout le monde même si on
n'est pas en appartement on énervé
donner le sentiment qu'il faut à chaque
fois se battre ils vivent parfois au
bord des routes nationales pas forcément
loin de paris mais toujours moins de
ceux qui les dirigent
moi je remarque qu'on y passe un tour de
tracteur et cnooc mèneront campagne il
faut savoir c'est qu'une vie différente
ils ont le sentiment d'être des français
de seconde zone comme s'ils étaient
invisibles ma forêt et dévoile un peu
plus aujourd'hui la france oubliée c'est
montrer ce qu'on ne voit jamais
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous savez
pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y a pas
d'alternative au sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave
est ce que c'est normal si on veut
sauver la vie sur terre il est probable
qu'il faille prendre un certain nombre
de mesures un peu autoritaire c'est
intéressant on comprend que vous soyez
des sous les libéraux l'uniforme c'est
quand même des hommes comment ces
mecs-là arrive à dormir la nuit là aussi
je pense qu'on a vécu quelque chose
d'inusité gilet jaune c'était des
valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas la louve
ligue parlementaire
ça se passe en direct puisque on est en
direct il y a quand même la liberté
je vous remercie de m'avoir amitié
[Musique]
nora lakehal a été la première femme à
intégrer le groupe
islamisme radical de la saur c'est
l'élite des renseignements généraux de
la police française
c'était après les attentats du 11
septembre et quand on vient vous voir et
qu'on vous dit ben écoutez vous avez de
la première femme qui allait rentrer
dans ce service
vous ne pouvez absolument pas refusé
votre mission première est celle de
traquer ces terroristes ce prêcheur
salafistes il vous a des tranchées pour
reprendre un code policiers il vous a
reconnu que si ben voilà c'est fini pour
moi est ce que je sors mon arme
tout est passé dans ma tête est ce que
vous avez appris de ces profils
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont chercher
d'ailleurs dans la religion le profil
vient toujours de la misère sociale
quand on écoute comme ça dit majeur mais
quel est le rapport avec la radiation
mais c'est la radicalisation
il faut que nous reprenions la place
dans le cerveau des enfants et de la
jeunesse
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bienvenue sur rt france en direct si
vous nous rejoignez 21h30 heure de paris
psa et fiat chrysler ont donné leur feu
vert ils deviennent officiellement une
entité appelée sté lantiss après deux
ans négociations et d'attendre cette
union est censé contrer la concurrence
japonaise ou encore allemande
une victoire pour les actionnaires des
deux groupes mais les salariés français
craignent de voir les usines fermées
plus de précision avec moderne où dès
lors elle ça y est c'est acté la fusion
psa fiat chrysler a été approuvé et le
groupe sera baptisée sts est l'anti ces
contrats quatre cent mille salariés dans
le monde est cette synergie regroupera
14 marques automobiles dont citroën
maserati opel alfa romeo ou encore jeep
une fusion qui se chiffre à près de 45
milliards d'euros d'après la valeur des
deux groupes en bourse cet élan this
devient donc le quatrième groupe
automobile mondial
il produira 9 millions de véhicules et
sera dirigé par carlos tavares et cette
alliance elle a du bon puisque grâce à
elle psa et fiat chrysler vont pouvoir
réduire leurs coûts de production et
améliorer leurs offres pour rattraper
les pertes liées à la crise sanitaire
les deux groupes respectifs profiteront
mutuellement de cette union pour
renforcer leur présence en europe quant
au groupe français et bien ce sera
l'occasion de plébisciter le marché
américain
finalement c'est une alliance profitable
qui leur permettrait d'économiser cinq
milliards d'euros par an sauf que cette
fusion est bien et là qui est les
syndicats de psa
quel sera son impact sur les emplois
dans les usines françaises
la direction de psa la garantie il n'y
aura pas de fermeture de site mais
quelques exemples passés de fusion
industriel incite à la prudence
on se souvient notamment des engagements
de l'américain general electric qui lors
de l'acquisition des activités énergie
d'alstom en 2014 s'était engagé à créer
1000 emplois en france
en quatre ans pour finalement s'apprêter
à supprimer 750 emplois
pour en avoir le coeur net il va falloir
être patient mais les syndicats échaudés
à temps
aujourd'hui costelle anti s'engagent à
ne pas fermer d'usiné temps au péril des
milliers d'emplois déjà fragilisées par
la crise sanitaire et pour en parler
nous sommes avec jean-pierre mercier
délégué syndical central cgt chez psa
porte parole de lutte ouvrière bonsoir
jean pierre merci merci d'être avec nous
alors une première réaction à cette
fusion entériné bonsoir oui bah écoutez
pour nous le le le seul point positif de
cette fusion c'est cette incroyable
force qui est né de 2 400 mille salariés
par delà les frontières par delà les
océans techniciens ingénieurs cadres
ouvriers ils représentent une force qui
va falloir qu'elle cette force elle soit
vraiment consciente d intérêt qu elle à
défendre des intérêts communs qui elle à
défendre par delà les frontières
parce que vous savez cette fusion votre
reportage là en partie évoquée il est
certain que l'objectif des actionnaires
de psa et de fiat et d'augmenter leur
rentabilité et de protéger leurs propres
intérêts et leurs propres intérêts ce ne
sont pas du tout les intérêts des
salariés de fiat et de psa et à psa on a
eu cette expérience malheureuse
concernant le rachat d'opel par par psa
carlos tavares s'était engagé à ne pas
fermer d'usiné certes il n'a pas fermer
d'usiné mais il a supprimé des milliers
d'emplois en allemagne en pologne en
angleterre dans les usines opel/vauxhall
donc c'est vrai que cette promesse c'est
vraiment qu'une promesse et les patrons
savent très bien supprimé des milliers
des dizaines de milliers d'emplois sans
avoir à fermer des usines
maintenant la crise sanitaire et le
break site
je pense ça va être de très bons
prétextes
mine de rien qui tombe à pic pour donner
des prétextes pour pour carlos tavares y
compris sans doute de fermer des usines
on ne sait pas encore dans quel pays
mais c'est évident que ce souci
d'augmenter sa rentabilité sa
compétitivité
ça va se faire sur le dos de l'ensemble
des salariés dans le même temps les
directions à
10 voilà c'était une question de survie
en terre c'était ça ou d'une certaine
manière on dise paris cède on
disparaissait dans un marché très
concurrentiel et très compliqué en ce
moment vous n'avez pas l'impression ce
soir plutôt d'avoir sauver votre peau
finalement sauvé la peau de l'entreprise
et des salariés qui vont avec
non pour qu'on sauve notre peau il va
falloir qu'on se bat
vous savez ça fait des années et des
années que psa accumulant engrange des
milliards sur milliards pas des records
financiers historiques chaque année et
pourtant il ya eu trente mille
suppressions d'emplois en france trente
mille suppressions de cdi en france
alors certes nous sommes dans une crise
économique extrêmement profonde
les actionnaires de psa de fiat fond de
calculs que en s'unissant ils vont
pouvoir protéger leurs intérêts et comme
le dit si bien carlos tavares une phrase
qui qui tourne dans toutes les usines
quand il va faire son tour de son tour
des usines
il va falloir aller manger dans la
gamelle des autres ça veut dire que les
actionnaires aujourd'hui sont en guerre
les constructeurs sont en guerre
économique entre eux et cette guerre
elle se fait sur le dos des salariés
avec la peau des salariés et c'est pas
parce que les intérêts des actionnaires
vont être protégés vont être mieux
protégés dans cette fusion que les
salariés vont en sortir vainqueur au
contraire on va avoir à faire face à d à
des plans de suppressions d'emplois à
des attaques sur notre pouvoir d'achat
pour réduire le droit collectif et par
delà les frontières
les salariés doivent absolument avoir
conscience qu'ils ont des intérêts
communs à défendre on soit un salarié
qui travaille aux états unis en italie
en france en allemagne en espagne en
angleterre
nous sommes maintenant touche liés par
le même patron qui va falloir combattre
est-ce que vous avez déjà pris de
contact justement avec ses autres
centrales américaines italiennes
ce que vous avez des points d'accord
vous vous sentez peut-être des
différences culturelles notamment avec
les américains qui n'ont pas forcément
la même façon de fonctionner que nous
bien sûr alors on avait déjà pris
contact avec les allemands avec la le
rachat d'opel par psa c'est sûr qu'il
s'est décidé au fis qui sont très
différentes des philosophies syndicale
très différentes on a pris déjà contact
avec les syndicats américains le
syndicat italien dont nous sommes nous
la cgt le le plus proche
il est il est certain que il va falloir
créer des ponts des passerelles prendre
contact discuter pour un autre sens
défendre cette idée principale que nous
allons devoir nous battre et nous unir
par delà les frontières
l'objectif la politique des actionnaires
représentés par carlos tavares va être
de mettre en concurrence les usines les
unes contre les autres les travailleurs
les uns contre les autres et travaillent
réellement contre les travailleurs
américains seuls les français contre les
espagnols etc
et ça c'est vraiment une politique qu'il
faut combattre une politique de division
parce que la danse est politique
les travailleurs en tout à perdre donc
il faut absolument oui qu'on défende
cette idée d'unité par delà les
frontières
en fait on est tous des camarades on est
tous des frères eux sont-ils justement
aussi inquiet que vous sur sur l'emploi
que ça soit les italiens ou les
américains les italiens oui ils sont
très propres et codip peu près préoccupe
excusez moi je devais vaudois dans les
jours à venir
avoir une discussion avec avec les
syndicats italiens
il est certain que la situation de siat
les actionnaires de fiat la famille
agnelli en fait toute une affaire que
ils sont ils sont en déficit
tout ça c'est des il prépare le les
réactionnaires prépare le terrain pour
mieux faire passer mieux faire accepter
tenter de faire accepter de justifier
des plans de suppressions d'emplois qui
sont inacceptables
en temps de crise économique on ne doit
pas supprimer le moindre emploi qu'ils
soient en cdi ou intérimaires donc il ya
des grandes batailles qui vont devoir se
jouer qui vont devoir se mener
et pour ça il faut qu'on
contact il faut qu'on discute il faut
qu'on prenne conscience qu'on a des
intérêts communs à mener contre nos
actionnaires aujourd'hui clairement ce
sera ma dernière question qu'est-ce que
ça va changer pour les salariés par
exemple en france tout de suite
immédiatement pas grand chose à court
terme extrêmement rapidement sans doute
sans doute certaines choses des
suppressions d'emplois on l'a où on l'a
vécu avec le rachat d'opel par psa ou
une partie de la r&d a été détruite en
france où carlos tavares a continué son
plan de suppression d'emplois là avec
fiat c'est pas un doublon qu'on va avoir
c'est un trip long psa opel fiat là
dedans il va y avoir une politique de
chaise musicale et sarah toucher les
salariés qui travaillent en france
aujourd'hui aucune catégorie
professionnelle ne peut se sentir
protégé aucun travailleur ne peut se
doit se sentir protégé merci beaucoup
jean pierre mercier délégué syndical
central cgt chez psa porte parole de
lutte ouvrière merci d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rt france l'union
européenne dénonce une situation
totalement inacceptable en bosnie
herzégovine un millier de migrants sont
privées d'abri après un incendie qui a
ravagé un camp dans le nord ouest du
pays et pour permettre aux réfugiés
d'accéder aux produits de première
nécessité trois millions et demi d'euros
ont été débloqués par les instances
européennes
amaya soubelet des migrants qui
survivent dans le froid et la neige
depuis l' incendie qui a ravagé le camp
de l'ipa le 23 décembre dernier plus
d'un millier d'entre eux sont livrés à
la précarité dans le nord ouest de la
bosnie l'union européenne a décidé ce
dimanche de débloquer 3 5 millions
d'euros supplémentaires d'assistance
humanitaire pour les réfugiés et
migrants dans le pays
dans son communiqué le chef de la
diplomatie européenne josep borrell
dénonce des conditions inhumaines
la situation est inacceptable un
hébergement adapté à l'hiver est
indispensable pour des conditions de
vies humaines qui doivent être garantis
à tout moment les autorités locales
doivent mettre à disposition leurs
structures existantes disponibles et
fournir une solution temporaire
d'hébergement en
attendant que le camp l'ipa soit
reconstruit en une infrastructure
permanente
une situation d'autant plus inquiétante
avec les conditions météo extrêmes et
une autre menace ajoute celle du
coronavirus que 8,19 s'est répandue ici
un campement temporaire pendant la
pandémie de kovy 19
ce n'est pas un lieu éligibles pour les
personnes vivant en hiver les voir la
situation ici
la température est en baisse négative et
le temps et glacial
nous ne voulons pas vivre ici est
déménagée dans les tentes parce que dans
cette situation
par ce temps le qu'on ne peut pas être
capable de vivre ici un appel à l'aide
qui tarde à se faire entendre du côté
des autorités locales
la classe politique bosnienne est
divisée face à la réponse à donner à la
crise migratoire entre pouvoir local et
pouvoir fédéral
les autorités de bihac se sont opposé à
la réouverture d'un centre dans le
centre ville en attendant ils survivent
depuis vendredi dans ces tentes
installées par les forces armées du pays
la bosnie accueille aujourd'hui quelques
8000 migrants qui restent bloqués aux
portes de l'europe
faustin archange touadéra réélu
président de la centrafrique et l'a
recueilli près de 54% des suffrages
selon la commission électorale
les résultats de la présidentielle ainsi
que de ceux des législatives doivent
être validé officiellement par la cour
constitutionnelle près d'éventuels
recours
des recours qui pourraient être nombreux
alors que plusieurs candidats ont
dénoncé une élection truquée la
communauté internationale redoute
également un embrasement du pays alors
que les groupes rebelles armés
contrôlent une large partie de la
centrafrique
pour en parler nous sommes avec yoakim
kokaté
istres conseiller de la présidence
centrafricaine bonsoir qui m'a kokaté
merci d'être avec nous le président
centrafricain faustin archange touadéra
réélu donc au premier tour c'est pas une
surprise comment accueillez-vous ce
résultat bonsoir tout ce que je peux
vous dire que ce n'est pas une surprise
les centrafricains ont démontré leur
volonté par la voie des urnes pour dire
tout simplement que ils sont des
démocrates le président faustin archange
touadéra lors de son premier mandat a
fait un travail très remarquable ce qui
a fait que les centrafricains millions
donné leur confiance en lui demandant de
de prendre encore la destinée du pays
pour un second mandat
oui sauf que l'opposition et des
détracteurs dénonce des élections
truquées ça va être compliqué d'unifier
le pays non dans ces conditions on pas
du tout vous avez suivi l'ancien
président françois bozizé qui avait
demandé aux centrafricains deux n'est
pas allé voter et laissant trafic est
rond au frais
le déplacement dans les différents
bureaux de vote pour remplir leur devoir
civique
ils ont démontré aux yeux de l'opinion
nationale internationale qui sera des
démocrates
donc il n'y a rien à faire malgré la
pression qui avait été faite par
monsieur françois bozizé avec ses amis
du coc div un voeu qui ont tout fait
pour empêcher qu'il y ait les élections
les centrafricains ont décidé d'aller et
s'exprimer je vais vous dire une chose
madame on a remarqué par exemple la
baignoire la 2d bambari monsieur andré
guindé a demandé aux autres africains de
cette localité de n'est pas allé voter
ils ont dit niet
ils ont ils sont venus malgré le coup de
feu organisé par la cpc des monsieurs
bouzid et de monsieur bozizé contre les
centrafricains sont trafiqués sont venus
ils ont exprimé
ils ont dit qu'ils doivent soutenir la
transition
la démocratie est une plonge jamais être
du côté de la violence cette violence
qui nous a été imposée par monsieur
bozizé avec les mercenaires qui la
réintroduira soit trafic rendez-vous toi
et qui constitue aujourd'hui la cpc ça
ne pourra jamais marcher et celles à la
majorité ce trafic un ont démontré par
ces élections que le peuple
centrafricain veut la paix le peuple
centrafricain veut le relèvement de son
pays et le peuple centrafricain a
confiance au président touadéra dont il
est hors de question de dire qu' il y
aura des idées des cuisses par ci par là
dans le même jour dans le même temps
plus tôt le même jour on apprend qu'une
enquête vise l'ancien président bozizé
hasard du calendrier peut-être cela peut
mettre le feu aux poudres selon vous
pas du tout l'ancien président bozizé
lui-même il a rompu le dialogue
alors à partir de ce moment qu'il a
rompu le dialogue la justice va
s'occuper de lui lajus au graphique elle
va s'occuper de lui et la cour pénale
internationale va s'occuper de lui avec
ses amis du coût de 20 vins qui ont
cherché par tous les moyens à empêcher
ces élections malheureusement pour eux
ces élections ça s'est bien déroulé dans
la transparence
ils sont trafiqués rondinaud à la
dictature les centrafricains ont dit non
aux mercenaires
les centrafricains ont dit oui à la
démocratie alors il n'y aura jamais
[Musique]
la guerre qui va cette guerre là que
monsieur bozizé avec les mercenaires de
la cpc a besoin de nous imposer à son
trafic
ça ne marchera pas la défaite ça sera de
leur côté tout simplement parce que le
peuple centrafricain
m et soutient la démocratie et le peuple
centrafricain soutient la politique du
président faustin archange touadéra la
preuve vous avez vu le président phocéen
à quoi je dois dire est revenu à 53,92
sont alors la communauté internationale
en tout cas redoute un embrasement du
pays est ce que c'est une crainte que
vous partagez nous nous savons que nous
avons des mercenaires en centrafrique en
ce moment nous avons nos amis nous avons
en france nous avons la russie nous
avons les rwandais nous avons là muscat
qui travaillent avec nous qui
travaillent avec nous dans ce contexte
là il n'y aura pas il n'y aura pas
l'embrasement c'est vrai qu'il ya des
poches de résistance principale
ils sont en train de mener des attaques
asymétriques
mais nous sommes en train de nous
organiser pour les mettre hors d'état de
nuire
afin de reprendre le contrôle total de
la sécurité la sécurité de notre pays
il ya eu la prise de benghazi hier cette
ville dont qui a été prise par les
rebelles qui occuperait deux tiers du
territoire sont ils selon vous en
position de force ces rebelles est ce
que vous avez et réussir à les combattre
seul mais tout ce que je peux vous dire
que nous avons les combattre nous avons
des forces amies nous savons nous avons
des forces amies qui sont venus en
centrafrique nous prêter main forte et
nous allons les mettre hors d'état de
nuire
c'est le voeu du peuple centrafricain
parce que le peuple centrafricain ne
veut plus en entendre parler de la
rébellion
je suis navré de voir que un ancien
président de la république qui soutient
officiellement la rue bériault ensuite
la question que je sois tu devais poser
et de lui poser est-ce qu'il a pitié du
peuple centrafricain
est-ce que la [ __ ] de ce pays demandez
aux mercenaires devenu le pilier répit
pendant trois jours
est ce que c'est ça un homme responsable
non les centrafricains vous barrer la
route à tous et aux groupes armés et aux
détracteurs de la république
merci joachim gauck été ministre
conseiller de la présidence
centrafricaine d'avoir été avec nous en
direct sur rt france et dans le reste de
l'actualité depuis le 1er janvier la
chine importe plus de déchets une
décision pour l'environnement voulu par
pékin mais qui a des répercussions
internationales
elle les flux de déchets des pays
occidentaux vers les pays d'asie du sud
est devraient s'intensifier
hélène masquelier jusqu'ici le contenant
en plastique que vous placez dans votre
bac de recyclage faisait un long voyage
à l'autre bout du monde
bien souvent jusqu'en chine pendant des
années les pays riches ont envoyé des
millions de tonnes de pots de yaourt
usagers de contenants de jus de fruits
et autres bouteilles de shampoing vers
la chine pour y être recyclés des
déchets nettoyer et broyés par des
entreprises chinoises locales puis
revendus aux industriels pour être
transformé un business très lucratif
pour l'industrie chinoise
rien qu'en 2016 les importations de
plastique ont rapporté 3 7 milliards de
dollars au pays
mais dès 2017 la chine réagit et
commence à interdire l'importation de
différents types de plastiques
une décision surtout motivé par la
protection de l'environnement
certains déchets étant difficiles à
recycler se retrouvent parfois rejetées
dans la nature
l'objectif est aussi de faire
disparaître ces villages poubelles qui
sont apparus dans le paysage chinois
malgré tout d'autres déchets continuent
d'être illégalement importées en chine
le tri sélectif n'est pas encore au
point et pas assez rigoureux le coût de
la récupération et du recyclage des
déchets restent élevés favorisant ainsi
les importations frauduleuses
conséquence de la fin des importations
de déchets par la chine les pays
exportateurs cherche de nouvelles
destinations pour les traiter pour
prendre le relais d'autres pays
asiatiques comme le vietnam la malaisie
ou encore la thaïlande mais les
capacités de recyclage dans ces pays
sont souvent limités les déchets
s'entassent dans des décharges sont
brûlés sans précaution ou finissent dans
la mer conscient du problème le vietnam
et la malaisie réduisent déjà leurs
importations de plastique pour ne pas
être submergé et commencent déjà à
renvoyer les containers illégaux à leurs
expéditeurs et c'est la fin de cette
émission rester avec nous on se retrouve
à 22 heures pour un point complet sur
l'actualité de ce lundi 4 janvier
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
métiers couple mythique n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vérité d idée
courageuse des mots qui comptent en soi
vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche extrême